hello everyone thank you for coming to
my talk so syndra and said I won't be
talking about
too much data science today I'll be
taking a more of an infrastructure
approach to the towing and data science
environment for your team or for your
group and don't worry if you have never
heard about kubernetes or you don't know
much about infrastructure I'll take a
sort of 10-foot approach so um I hope
you'll get something out of it
so I'm Camilla I write Python Java and
go and I usually work across the stack
so I've worked with a big data and a bit
with cloud and a variety of things at
the moment I run a platform called spine
labs that helps nonprofits and teams
deployed Jupiter hub in the cloud so
yeah I like to talk about Python Jupiter
and coffee and cats
and I've had too much coffee this
morning already so don't offer me
another one but if you want to talk
about anything else just you can find me
on Twitter or just come and grab me
after you talk so before we dive in just
by a show of hands who here has used
Jupiter in notebooks for like okay so
pretty much everyone so I was going to
actually I'm going to show a bit of a
live demo if the demo gods are in my
favorite today so this is a Jupiter hug
that I have running on a kupuna days
cluster so I'm just going to log in and
show you what you can what you can sort
of do with a platform like this so when
you log into a Jupiter hub it will give
you the standard Jupiter notebook
interface and you can bootstrap your own
Jupiter user server so this will
hopefully work might take a a few
minutes to start up okay something's
happening right so if you've used the
Jupiter noted before you know that you
get an interface like this that allows
you to create basically an interactive
computing environment that can be backed
up by various different languages I
think at this point the Jupiter
community has about 100 different
kernels that you can use including our
for our friends in the our data science
community so basically what you can do
is you can start up a new notebook and
you can type something execute code do
interactive graphics and various things
like that go back to the slides okay so
I think he threw them oh gods
this is not right so the Jupiter project
was started by a PhD student called
Fernando Paris when he was finishing up
his degree and it was first known as
ipython so if you read the Python
community like five or 10 years ago you
might have heard about the ipython
notebook which was the previous
incarnation of Jupiter so it has now
grown from the original ipython version
to a large ecosystem that supports
multiple programming languages and I
mentioned our before but I believe
there's also support for Scala and
various other ones it also has a very
large ecosystem of additional projects
such as Jupiter hub which allows you to
deploy and manage multiple notebooks for
a team for example Jupiter lab which is
the next generation of browser-based
interfaces for interactive computing as
well as many others so you can find more
information about the community in
Jupiter org in addition to that Jupiter
has an active open-source community and
there is a large team of maintainer x'
now various flock Chanos mailing lists
as well as a jupiter conference that
takes place in new york i think they had
the first one last year and there there
will definitely be one this year not
only is Jupiter known in the PI data
community it's also seeing very wide
adoption across various industries and
scientific disciplines a few years ago I
think even nature was doing some sort of
interactive scientific papers on their
website and that was powered by Jupiter
notebooks also recently Jupiter has
become this
contender former proprietary solutions
such as Mathematica so there is a blog
post recently by by someone whose name
I've just forgotten but he was basically
comparing Mathematica to Jupiter and
saying that the Jupiter ecosystem has
come quite far so it is definitely no
serious competition for more commercial
and proprietary based solutions so
definitely be interesting to see what
happens in the coming years to the open
interactive computing space so as I
mentioned before Jupiter is great for
doing data science because it can
support support multiple programming
languages you can export it an avoid
variety of formats share it with people
because the way the Jupiter notebooks
are stored is using JSON so you can have
a wide variety of ways to share it you
can also do interactive visualizations
animations and a bunch of other things
so if you're not yet using Jupiter for
your own data science needs I definitely
encourage you to take a look so lots of
people in this room are probably more
than capable of installing Jupiter on
their own machines and managing any
kinds of installation problems but what
happens if you're running a class like a
university class for 400 people and you
have people from various backgrounds
some of who may have never used Python
before or may have never had to install
anything before so you quickly get into
various kinds of issues that can cause
you more great hair than you want to so
this is something known as that I've
called installation drift so basically
people install different versions of
scientific computing packages they have
different operating systems you have
some people that don't have admin
privileges you have some operating
systems that don't work well with
package managers for example and things
like that
even though package managers such as
paper and the content distribution have
made it relatively easy it's so possible
that if you're running a team or you
have a class where you're teaching
programming you spend a lot of time
debugging various kinds of compilation
errors and
Aires and also when you have a duty to
yourself approach so that everyone has
to local version of a Jupiter notebook
you quickly get into problems such as it
works on my machine because maybe they
have some version of sci-fi or an empire
but then when you try to show the
notebook the results are different
so basically Jupiter help is developed
as a solution to these kinds of problems
and it's meant to help you have a
centralized way to deploy a reproducible
Jupiter notebook environments for
hundreds of users so let's look a little
bit at the Jupiter hub internals and see
how exactly it works under the hood so
in this diagram we have our two familiar
eye components the user's browser so
this is Chrome or Firefox whatever you
use to interact with your Jupiter
notebook and then we have the Jupiter
notebook server that's the actual
back-end that's listening to your
commands executing your code and sending
output back to your browser so Jupiter
hub sits in between these two and it
listens to connections from users
browsers and then thus logic to to make
sure that everything works well so what
are some of the things that Jupiter hub
has to do in order to make this work
well so first when a user sends a
request it has to authenticate the user
to make sure that they're allowed to
perform these actions because we're
essentially allowing users to execute
code on our platform we have to be quite
careful that we don't just open this up
too to anyone that can lead to severe
security issues and problems downstream
so authentication then we have to check
if this user who's trying to connect is
a new user if she is a new user then we
spin up a new Jupiter notebook server
and redirect her to that server if not
if not if the user already has an
running Jupiter notebook server like I
just showed you and then we have to make
sure that her requests are redirected to
that server so the way we achieve this
is we actually have two components that
form our Jupiter hub
we have a configurable HTTP proxy which
is actually a JavaScript component that
sits between the users and the internal
components of Jupiter hub so the
configurable proxy is made up of two
HTTP servers one of them is facing the
internet and is listening to requests
coming from users browsers the other one
is facing the internal hub components
and is communicating with the hub so the
hub itself is a Python process that
takes care of authentication spawning an
individual users notebook server and
then also communicating with the proxy
so it happens if we have a new user who
is just connecting to the Jupiter hub
system is that her request will first be
intercepted by the configurable HTTP
proxies public-facing component the
proxy will establish that the user has
never before had running notebook
notebook because there is no entry for
her in the proxies routing tables so
then the proxy will forward the request
to the hub the hub you check if the user
is authenticated and is allowed to spin
up a notebook and then if she is a lot
to spin up a notebook the hub will
communicate with the proxies internal
facing component to establish a new
routing rule for the user which means
that the next time the user wants to
talk to her notebook she won't have to
go through the whole process of
authenticating with the hub so that's
sort of in a nutshell how Jupiter hub
works under the hood so I was going to
do another live demo but I thought I
wouldn't push my luck with the demo gods
I made a little recording that I'm
hoping to hear you at least a few bits
of what this system looks like under the
hood when it's running so I have that is
very small one second bear with me I'm
going to zoom in a little bit so I have
a kubernetes cluster running on Google
Cloud that's running a very small three
node cluster and a Jupiter hub
and I'm just going to show you what
happens in the proxy when I
right so this is can everyone see you up
now let's try to make it a little bit
bigger can everyone see this out in the
back as well okay cool so this is our
Jupiter hub deployment on kubernetes so
you can see we're calling I'll go over
this in more detail later but for now
we're calling kubernetes and we're
asking you to tell us which components
are running on our system so the pods so
we see that we have a hub approxi and
then we have a few other components that
basically just make sure that everything
runs smoothly so those are running now
so this is before any user has connected
to our hub so I'm going to fast forward
now to the moment where I've actually
connected to the hub with my browser so
one second let me just go to 255 right
so right here you can see Jupiter canola
so this is my notebook server that has
started up and it's actually it's
running as a pod on the kubernetes
cluster so if you let this run a bit
more I'm going to look at the proxy logs
now and I'll see if I so I see that
basically here I've connected to Jupiter
hub and in this line you can see the
Jupiter harvest has authenticated me and
it's talking back to configurable HTTP
proxy and it's basically saying this
user is allowed to spin up a notebook
I've just done it for her and I've added
this root user slash Camilla so the next
time I login the proxy will
automatically redirect me to my notebook
without having to go through the hub
again okay back to slides
so now you've seen a little bit of how
Jupiter hug works under the hood but
what do we have to do in order to
actually productionize this and make it
safe for users for lots of users to use
there are some challenges that we will
face so first of all managing CPU and
memory resources responsibly we're going
to have several users sending code
snippets to our back-end the Jupiter
server to execute and we don't really
know what these users will do so some of
the users might be malicious and
intentionally try to start the system
for example by launching something
really CPU intensive or it could be just
accidental so we have to find a way to
limit the users process to only use a
certain amount of CPU and memory so that
we can share the platform among multiple
users
second of all we have to find a way to
clean up resources that aren't used
anymore
so for example stale notebooks or files
things like that
if you're running a public Jupiter hub
for example in a platform like clan
topia we have to be able to scale up and
down our cloud computing resources on
demand for example if there's a big
class and it's starting up you might
have 500 users trying to access jupiter
hub at the same time and in cases like
these you can't really rely on manual
intervention to log into your cloud
provider and provision more compute for
your jupiter hub service last but not
least you have to be able to manage
security appropriately so authentication
and also securing the connections
between your users browsers and the
notebook so let's look at some recent
developments in the infrastructure space
that enable us to manage these
challenges so the first challenge that
we had was making sure that each process
each jupiter server process is isolated
and doesn't use more memory or compute
capacity than we allocated to and in
recent years a development that has made
this possible is containerization sir
container is a logical concept accusers
operating system features to isolate
processes from one another and to make
sure that they don't use more computer
today then is allocated to them
container whose technology are actually
not very new they originated in the late
70s early 80s but didn't really gain
wide acceptance until 2006 when Google
deployed a Linux kernel patch that
allowed for process isolation and this
became known as control groups so even
at that point people still weren't using
containers very widely unless they had
some kind of specialized me to do this
and this was because there wasn't really
a way for you to easily package your
applications as containers and then run
them so this will change with a startup
called docker that made a platform for
people to create containerized images
things that you could share between
users upload them to container
repositories download them and then be
able to run them so containers have
solved our first challenge we can now
isolate processes we can isolate our
jupiter notebook servers and we can also
create reproducible deployment
environments which is really good we can
just package up our application all of
its dependencies and then we can simply
deploy it to our favorite cloud provider
and be done with it without having to
get gray hairs worrying about
installations or updating our
dependencies manually so to deploy a
jupiter hub we would need to spin up a
container for every user's notebook
server depending on the number of users
this could be hundreds we also need a
container to run our hub and a container
for our considerable HTTP proxy so for
small deployments you might be ok just
manually restarting these containers on
your chosen container runtime or having
some kind of bash script to do this for
you but if you're running a large-scale
production deployment you have to
prepare for the worst case what if one
of your cloud virtual machines fails
what if you need to redeploy something
while you have active users will you be
able to do some kind of load balancing
if you certainly have an influx of users
will you be able to redirect your users
to machines in an alternative failover
zone for example if one of your data
centers goes out so these are some of
the questions that you might think about
before you deploy your containers
application into the cloud and do
worrying about all of this manually is
not usually possible because in a
situation where you would for example
have to load balanced users to to
another availability zone there just
simply won't be enough time or manpower
for you to let's say manually SSH into
the machines and make the required
changes so this has been a recognized
problem in the industry and what we've
developed to solve this is container
orchestration platforms so different
kinds of software that manage your
containerized processes for you and
there are two key I guess features of
these platforms so first we have to talk
about clustering this usually means that
we have a collection of cloud-based
virtual machines that act as a single
machine from the point of view of the
client application so your jupiter
health components shouldn't really care
about which exact machine they're
deployed to they should be agnostic in
this sense so the cluster essentially
acts as one machine which makes it easy
for you to fail over to another cluster
if you have a machine failure let's say
the second component of the software is
the actual orchestration itself so you
need some kind of component that will
take care of things for you scheduling
and managing your containers load
balancing failover restarting containers
that failed and so forth there are
several software products in the market
that will help you do this but the
Jupiter hub team has made a a choice to
go with kubernetes which is an open
source orchestration system first
developed at Google and open sourced I
think a few years ago so the kubernetes
community has been growing quite rapidly
a few years ago the main kubernetes
conference cube con had a few hundred of
these
but last year in Austin Texas the
conference had grown into four thousand
attendees so the open source project and
it's adoption is definitely growing
which kubernetes offers you is it offers
you a cluster of nodes where you
schedule your applications and a master
which takes care of things such as
storing the cluster state checking on
the health of the nodes and
so five so there are two sort of main
advantages that you have may use
kubernetes so in the past in the DevOps
space we have had two philosophies of
how you provision your machines to
deploy applications such as Jupiter hub
one of them is declarative and the other
is imperative so in an imperative mode
you basically write a little recipe of
the exact exact steps that you need to
perform in order for your machine to be
ready to deploy an application such as
Jupiter hub the other way to do this is
declarative so instead of writing down
the steps that you need to do you define
what you want the state of the
infrastructure to be so we want hard
kubernetes cluster to have three nodes
we want each of our applications to have
two replicas and so forth but you don't
define how this should be achieved so
this frees you from having to worry
about how things are achieved and
instead kubernetes can work for you to
continuously make sure that the reality
of the cluster and its health reflects
the state that you want it to be
additionally kubernetes allows us to
abstract infrastructure so instead about
worrying individual machines or low
level networking details we have an
abstract set of infrastructure objects
pods services they represent different
kinds of things about Howard Jupiter
hubs should be running and how it should
be deployed this usually makes it easier
for people who don't have much
experience in the infrastructure space
like me for example to have a functional
kubernetes deployment so the way that
you would deploy a kubernetes
application is you create these kinds of
llamó
configuration files and then you send
post requests to arrest api that's on
the kubernetes master and then the
kubernetes will prepare these services
will make sure that your application is
deployed to the node for smaller things
this is okay
writing llamo by hand but for larger
projects like jupiter hub for example
where you have several components that
need to communicate with each other this
can get quite tedious and also you won't
be able to forget
or rollback or upgrade very easily
because you have multiple configuration
files that need to be changed
simultaneously so to make this easier
the kubernetes community has developed
something called helm
it's a package manager for kubernetes
that exists on the client so it exists
both from the client saw on the shell
terminal that you're using to
communicate with your cluster and there
is also a component on the cluster
itself called tiller which receives
these commands and then make sure that
your application stage reflects what you
want it to be so he'll basically allows
you to share kubernetes deployments as
home charts and it also makes it easy
for you to upgrade or rollback
applications so the good news is that
the Jupiter team has has already
produced a good home chart for us to use
so you don't
if you are trying to deploy Jupiter hub
for example in your own cloud
infrastructure you don't have to worry
about too much about writing these
yourself right so to prepare for this
talk I tested out the open source
Jupiter hub palm charts on three
different commercial cloud providers
Google Cloud kubernetes engine Amazon
unfortunately doesn't have a native
kubernetes solution yet they've recently
launched something called eks but it was
still in preview mode only so I wasn't
able to to run tests with that and if
you're more of a do-it-yourself kind of
person there are two approaches to
deploy in communities and Jupiter hub on
Amazon so you can use a hep tio
CloudFormation template that will deploy
all the components for you or you can
use a command line tool called cops
both of these do require a bit of extra
effort to set up things properly and
also extra effort to manage the
deployment last but not least there is
Microsoft Azure container service which
is also still in preview but you can
it's already public so you can you can
try it out so google kubernetes engine
it's definitely the easiest of these to
work with things pretty much work out of
the box you download the home chart from
Jupiter hubs open source repository and
then
you run a few commands using Google's
native shell tool and if things just
things work without any hiccups the
other good part about this is that you
don't actually have to manage any part
of kubernetes yourself the google
kubernetes engine comes free of charge
and the only thing you pay for is the
actual compute instances but make up
your note so I did I did some pricing
comparisons and if you want to run a
small demo of Jupiter hub with three
nodes and one virtual CPU in a bit of
RAM if you run in 24/7 for a month the
cost will be about 70 pounds so then the
next the next trial I did was kubernetes
and Jupiter have an AWS so as mentioned
before they don't have a native
kubernetes solution which definitely
makes it a lot harder to get a fully
functional deployment I didn't try out
hefty O's CloudFormation template but I
did make a cluster with cops this does
require quite a lot of knowledge about
configuring DNS servers for example sort
of the internal kubernetes components
can talk to each other and this will
also be more expensive for you in the
long run because you have to manage the
kubernetes eenz that run the kubernetes
infrastructure itself whereas with
Google Cloud solution you get that sort
of for free you just pay for the nodes
that actually will run your Jupiter hub
deployment if you're interested there is
a link to a demo of deploying helm
charts and the whole jupiter hub process
on a cluster created with mult last but
not least the is your container service
so this is more similar to google cloud
in many ways you just have a simple
command line process for deploying
jupiter hub it's relatively easy apart
from a few hiccups which is expected
because they're still in preview mode
but other than that it does work very
easily
IKS is also similar to the Google cloud
kubernetes engine in the sense that it
doesn't charge you anything for the
actual maintenance of the cluster only
for your compute node some kubernetes
features unfortunately are not yet
available in IKS so for example if you
want to have
based access restrictions to your
kubernetes cluster so you have an admin
that's allowed to do some things and
some other users and that's not yet
available on the O'Hare system and
although you can't really compare the
Google cloud and the issue offering like
one to one because the machine sizes
that you use for your nodes are slightly
different I tried to pick out things
that were as close to each other
as I could so if you run a small demo
cluster with one core and 3.5 gigabytes
of RAM it would be about 82 pounds per
month if you're under 24/7 so usually
when when you make the choices for
deploying an application such as Jupiter
having to the cloud and I usually make a
little matrix of things that matter
matter to me and then I compare the
different providers based on that so you
might want to do a similar exercise in
your team if you're planning to deploy
Jupiter hub so for me the most important
things are is it easy to deploy I don't
have much in-depth knowledge of
networking and infrastructure so the
tools have to work pretty much out of
the box is it easy to deploy the
application itself so how easy is it
make to how easy is it to get Jupiter
hub with helm to work and actually the
good news is that once you've got the
kubernetes cluster set up on whatever
cloud provider you need the the part
that comes after that is super easy
because how is actually cloud agnostic
so if even if you want to migrate from
Azure let's say to Google cloud you can
keep a big chunk of your deployment
infrastructure because helm doesn't
really care what sort of underneath
that's the good news is that once you've
got the cluster set up the deployment
part is very easy on all three cloud
providers and then you also have to
think about the costs so with Google
Cloud and sure you get the kubernetes
part for free
whereas with AWS at least until they
launch he casts you'll still have to pay
for the computer instances that run the
actual infrastructure itself so to
summarize we've seen how Jupiter can
make your data science experience better
and how Jupiter hub can make it easier
for large teams to have reproducible
and highly available Jupiter environment
we've looked at some Jupiter hub
components under the hood and how
jupiter works and we've also looked at
some of the infrastructure developments
that have happened in recent years to
enable us to provision these kind of
highly available infrastructures in the
cloud so yeah that's pretty much all I
had and I'll be happy to take any
questions that you have now or after the
talk
[Applause]
okay so the question was about whether I
have looked at binder and other
extensions to drifter hub and the answer
is no unfortunately I've been working
with vanilla Jupiter hub deployment but
certainly it would be happy to take a
look yes so I've tried to deploy things
like ghupat er how about a kubernetes
cluster but I tend to work in a private
cloud environment where you want to give
users access to the persistent storage
they're used to running on that same
environment so unlike saying that in a
DCP sort of environment where you can
spit up a volume that's unique to that
user try to integrate it with that
established thing you could you sort of
comment on or the development in terms
of how to Patong up and the persistent
storage on not the public cloud if
you're not trying to run it on a sure
tcp but on something else is that being
actively worked on cuz that's my pain
point right now so are you running
kubernetes in your private cloud I've
tried I've set it up these are these are
these are cloud platforms traditionally
this sort of like pre-allocated I don't
have the ability to spin up brand-new
nodes that they're sort of set there
think about more closer to bare metal
kind of things as opposed to a full
kubernetes installation so if you do it
on kubernetes you can definitely have
something called persistent volume
claims which will sort of allocate for
every user of persistent volume that is
persisted even if the actual pod that's
running the container dies now I mean
you can strip off all of this
obstruction and go down to the docker
container itself and that obviously
allows you to mount a volume that can
that may persist it so I mean you might
have to go down there without the whole
kubernetes part but unfortunately I
can't comment exactly on how
our work okay that's good thank you what
do you think about the pros and cons of
services like say Jamaica and whatever
GCP will offer as an alternative that
will also allow you to spin up notebooks
seems like in an even more abstracted
away than this vs. Jupiter hopeless
communities I know that there are
several cloud-based providers that are
doing things like Jupiter hub but as far
as I know things like collabs and Anna
sage maker there are single notebook
environments for a user but I think
Jupiter hub is is more useful for
example when you're in a university you
have maybe some legal /ip issues where
you can't use a public cloud notebook
like private data or research data and
you need your own deployment but apart
from that I don't really have any other
comments I haven't actually used any of
those publicly available Jupiter
notebooks hello so I was wondering for
this small cluster that you had with
three notes and one CPU do you have any
idea of how many notebooks so how many
Ducker containers you can actually run
well keeping it stable that's a very
good question and I was going to do some
performance measuring before before I
came here and unfortunately I didn't
have time so that would definitely be a
good extension to this talk I've tried
running about five or ten containers and
yeah five or ten Jupiter servers in
containers but without doing anything
act super intensive actually so I
wouldn't know how they would behave that
that was pretty stable but I wouldn't
know how they would behave if I tried to
like compute fractals in the notebook or
something else that takes a present
runner computer I have a couple of
questions so first one is the
architecture or the implementation that
you did will also work for a true Petare
lab which is the next release coming up
you look into that I have not tried you
inner hub I have not tried to deploy
Jupiter having this modular lab
this matters so I fortune cannot comment
on that but in this particular case it
would work with the other things that
support that are supported by Jupiter
like Julia for example will be fine
I would assume yes great and then the
big thing about a lot of this Jupiter
notebook is that we share a lot of data
I mean one of the biggest problem is if
it's somewhere in a machine somewhere
you have to move that data to that
machine have you found a way of easily
resolving that issue and also
maintaining security for the data itself
this is probably really bad to say
because of gdpr and other stuff that's
coming up with now I haven't I haven't
found a good way
I mean Jupiter well kubernetes has many
add-ons and plugins that you can use to
make it really secure and whenever you
deploy things like Jupiter hub as a
public service you should always for
example make sure you use SSL and the
good part about Jupiter hub is that
they've made it really really easy for
people who have no previous experience
in configuring encryptions to spin up an
SSL connection between every user and
the notebook server so there are some
built-in features that definitely make
it sort of secure but for a large
amounts of data I wouldn't be able to
say unfortunately thank you
hey let's say I have a environment with
100 occasional users that will use a
notebook maybe twice per month does
Jupiter hop somehow handle spinning up
and tearing down instances as the
compute power is needed or not needed
anymore
yes it does do that so the question is
about spinning up and basically deleting
unused notebooks and yes there is an
automatic mechanism in Jupiter hub that
will call notebooks once they've been
inactive for a certain period of time I
can't remember off the top of my head
what that is but it's definitely
configurable so if your user closes the
browser but those forgets to stop the
notebook server than yeah in a few hours
and I think communities or Jupiter hub
will tear it down and the kubernetes
cluster itself can scale up and down
depending on on your needs so you can
set up auto scaling so it can go up to
six nodes for example if that's what you
need and then Jupiter will sort of
manage that for you but it will
definitely clean up stuff that's not
used
[Applause]